Hi there, Steve Kaufmann.
Um, today I want to talk about
language learning apps, language
learning tools, the language
learning environment that we live in.
Uh, remember if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
You know, you can click on
the bell to get notifications.
Um, I've been learning
languages since, I don't know...
I mean, we had French at school
and I got particularly keen
as a 17 year old, 18 year old.
In Montreal at the McGill university,
uh, ultimately went to France, uh,
studied Chinese, studied Japanese, or
learned it, living in Japan and had
learned a bunch of other languages.
And that goes back over 50 years, never
has it been easier to learn languages.
And part of the reason is because
of the variety of call them
language apps, uh, language tools.
Uh, language services that
are available to us today.
And I'm only going to touch on a
few of them because I can't remember
them all, but let's just start
with, you know, uh, smartphones.
I carry in my iPhone, a language lab,
a range of audio and text material that
will be the envy of any language lab
50 20, 30, 40 years ago, the range of
material that I have, and if my phone
gets full, I can park them into my
computer and get them later so that,
that, and I can listen on my iPhone.
I can do LingQ on my iPhone.
I can read, I can look things up.
I can go to Google Translate on my
iPhone or other dictionaries and I'm
just touching the surface because
other people, I mean, the range of
language apps that you can find in
the, in the App Store is, is enormous.
It's so many that you, you don't know
which ones are going to be useful.
Many of them are not very useful, but
I think the, the smartphone itself,
and of course, you know, similar to
the smartphone, you have the iPad,
which I tend to use more for language
learning, especially if I'm working
on LingQ or, uh, the iPod touch,
which I use when I go jogging or when
I, you know, don't want to take my
phone with me cause it's too heavy.
Basically
providing the same range of services,
including, you know, studying on LingQ.
So that's to start with.
Uh, MP3 technology of course
has made it so much easier to
access audio than ever before.
You don't have to go buy CDs.
You don't have open reel tapes.
You don't have, um, you
know, cassette tapes.
You just have MP3 files, which you
send back and forth to your friends,
which you can find you can download.
You can subscribe to podcasts.
There's another call it service.
The range of language podcasts, not
only aimed at learners, but what I
prefer to use is podcasts aimed at the
native speaker on a variety of subjects.
Um, you know, YouTube, YouTube
has a great variety of, uh,
videos, some aimed at the learner,
some not.
Very often, subtitles are
provided in the target language.
Uh, with that, I can import those
into LingQ and study them as lessons.
So there's an unlimited
supply in certain languages,
unfortunately, not in all languages.
And there are issues, for example,
learning in Standard Arabic.
There are very few videos
with both the audio and the
subtitles in standard Arabic.
So there's an issue there, but
nevertheless, there's so much
there that you can go to now.
In order to make sense of what
I'm listening to, uh, whether it
be podcasts or, or even Netflix,
I shouldn't leave out Netflix.
We can download series there.
We can download the dialogue to LingQ.
We can't capture the audio, but
I can go through the dialogue
and learn the words and phrases.
And of course their online
dictionaries become important.
Online dictionaries are extremely
important to LingQ because even
in every language, the learner,
depending on their native language
can look up with the lang...
with the dictionary of their choice.
There are certain choice dictionaries
that are particularly useful.
I am told that Jisho in
Japanese is particularly good.
I don't study Japanese, so I have no way
of commenting other than apparently it's
an excellent dictionary, which provides
you with stroke order for characters,
different meanings, different phrases, uh,
that use the words that you're looking up.
Uh, I find Context
Reverso to be tremendous.
Gives you a range and this is typical of
what the online dictionaries provide now
is a range of phrases using the word.
Very often they'll give
you text to speech.
Context Reverso has a conjugating
dictionary and there are other
conjugating dictionaries so that if you
look up a word, you can immediately see
the conjugation or...
it's not so common for declensions.
Unfortunately, the declensions being,
you know, nouns and adjectives, which
change form, but for verbs it's quite
common to have the ability to go and see
sort of the conjugation table, uh, which
I never tried to remember, but as I look
at it more often, I get closer and closer
to a sense of how, how that verb works.
Remembering always that it's going to
be a lot of exposure before it starts to
click in, but I mentioned text to speech.
There's a tremendous
resource, text to speech.
If I'm reading something in particular,
in Arabic, where it's hard to tell just
how something is pronounced text to
speech tells me how it's pronounced.
Now, I can't listen to a whole lesson
in text to speech, but I can listen to
words and phrases in text to speech.
I still don't have text to speech in
Persian, which is very unfortunate,
but we haven't been able to find a text
to speech service that fits with the
other service that we provide at LingQ.
Uh, Google Translate what a
tremendous service, you know, I, I,
uh, have my, uh, Uh, you know, my
online sessions with tutors and I
struggle to say certain things and
even after I'm still struggling.
How do you actually say that?
It, because the phrasing is kind of
mysterious and, and so I'll go to Google
Translate and I type it in, in English.
I want to go.
I went yesterday.
I should go.
Anything that, you know, has a verb form
or tense, or mood, or some structure
that I find difficult to get a hang
of in the language that I'm learning.
I just type it in, in English.
I get it in the target language.
And so I, I often go to Google Translate,
not only to look up the meaning of a word
in the foreign language that I'm learning,
but also to see how I would go about
saying something in that target language.
So that's a tremendous app.
Um, I mentioned podcasts, many podcasts,
perhaps most don't have transcripts.
Without the transcript I'm kind of
in trouble because, uh, depending
on how far along I am in the
language, I may only understand
20 or 30% without the transcript.
With the transcript I can import
it into LingQ, look up the words,
learn the words, but without the
transcripts, it's very difficult.
And it's frustrating to listen
to things over and over again
that you don't understand.
So automatic transcription services, which
I mentioned before, like Happyscribe.
Quite, I mean, remarkably
accurate and they're all
getting more and more accurate.
Like all of these apps are
getting better and better.
I can remember even with LingQ when I
was, you know, I was taking three or four
seconds to look up a word and, and now
it's, it's instant and I don't want to
talk too much about LingQ 5.0, because,
because Mark tells me not to talk about
it because it's so complex because
we are, we are, um, writing code, not
me, but the people within our team are
writing code for the iOS system for
Android and for the, the web application.
And so there's the back
and that has to be changed.
And there's, there's, it just it's
taking much longer than we expected,
but it is going to be even better.
So, um, just as you know, Google
Translate was much worse before.
Right now, Google Translate, which
is also sort of machine translation
AI is remarkably accurate.
Uh, automatic transcription is
remarkably accurate and all of these
things are only going to get better.
Similarly with LingQ, I think it's
only going to get better, again, an
indication of the world we live in.
We have developers working on the
LingQ project with my son, Mark.
I'm not involved, uh, from, uh,
okay ukraine, korea, Portugal,
two in Ghana, uh, one in Bolivia.
Um, we have, uh, you know, our
customer service people in Serbia.
It's an absolute, it's an international
cooperative venture, uh, which is again,
an indication of the world we live in
where we are connecting and because we
can connect so easily with, with people.
And I did mention, I think
I mentioned italki, there's
another wonderful application.
They have such a wide range of
tutors, uh, with different price
levels and different skill sets.
And you can choose the one you want.
Uh, we also offer, uh, tutoring at
LingQ, but we don't have the range
of tutors that they have at italki.
So, you know, and there again,
I've only touched on a few things.
There are people who use Anki, Memrize.
I don't use those, so I don't want
to talk too much about them because
I'm not that familiar with them.
Uh, so this is the world we live in.
This is the world we live in so that
language learning today, because of
this abundance of, of, uh, wonderful
functionality that people are creating...
and six months from now, there
will be people who will have
created other, um, you know, apps
that help us learn languages.
So whenever I hear people say, well,
you know, with AI, we won't need to
learn languages because we'll just
be able to talk to the machine and
then the machine will translate and
the conversation will go that way.
I don't believe it for a minute.
I think the joy of communicating
face-to-face with someone in another
language, the joy of discovering
their culture, as I have been doing
now, talking to my tutors in Iran and
discovering that one lives in ... Which
is in a, in Golestan in the North.
Is that what I, I can't remember anymore.
One lived in Lahijan ... I think.
I can't remember.
See, that's the other thing
you forget everything.
But if I got into the
conversation, I'd remember.
But so you're connecting,
you're learning languages.
You're connecting with people.
Why would people give that up?
Just in order to talk to a machine?
I don't see it.
The language apps are making the
language journey easier, and people are
going to be more and more successful.
And so I see a very bright
future for language learning.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.